l'acquisition de chat par rogers et dans
l'incertitude après un avis défavorable
du bureau de la concurrence l'organisme
fédéral affirme que cette transaction va
faire grimper les prix réduire la
qualité des services diminuer la
concurrence en particulier dans le sans
fil les deux entreprises restent engagés
à poursuivre cette transaction de 26
milliards de dollars un des enjeux c'est
l'avenir de freedom aubert qui
appartient chat et qui doit être vendue
à une autre entreprise et voilà que
quebecor a été invité à se joindre à la
course pour acheter possiblement fruit
de maubert on en parle avec johanne
lemay qui est coprésidente de l'homme
est fière de s'associer bonsoir
spécialistes du secteur bien sûr des
télécommunications est-ce que c'est
surprenant que de bureau de la
concurrence prennent cette décision
d'abord en fait pour le mâle canada oui
parce que disons qu'en général au canada
le bureau de la concurrence n'a pas les
mêmes dans new traditionnellement pas eu
les dents aussi aiguisée par exemple que
la federal trade commission aux états
unis alors oui c'est un peu surprenant
par contre est-ce que c'est surprenant
qu'il dise que l'acquisition amènerait
une baisse de la concurrence pour
nécessairement parce que je pense qu'ils
ont du bon point dans ce qu'ils amènent
c'est intéressant de lire le communiqué
qu'ils ont mis aujourd'hui parce
qu'évidemment ils ont regardé les côtés
câblodistribution internet ils ont gardé
le côté sans fil ils ont gardé les
services aussi de faire et tous à bon
escient lui sont dans la conclusion que
la seule place où le bât blesse mais non
la moindre c'est le côté s'en fait comme
on s'y attendait d'ailleurs et ils n'ont
pas mentionné
si on se fie vous rappelle quand vous
intimide n'ont pas mentionné les offres
qui résume à leur ont été présentées de
l'explorer est ni de groupe aquilini les
deux groupes qui ont été mentionnées
dans les journaux récemment qu'ils
peuvent acheter mme barber et xi était
sur les rats étaient sur les rangs pour
acheter fruits le moba dont l'un se fait
plus qu'un an que cette acquisition l'a
été mais non moi je se tourneraient
selon le globe and mail revers quebecor
parce que ça c'est surprenant mais ce
qui est surprenant c'est qu'il n'est pas
fait encore parce que quebecor depuis le
début et est en bonne position pour
participer associés maintenant radieuse
dans les normes pour les façons de
procéder à la canadienne
trop loin quand même à se contrôler sûr
qu'il invite pour soumissionner pour
freedom et peut-être qu'ils voulaient
pas voir quebecor nécessairement dès le
début parce que quebecor je pense sur un
concurrent fort pour rogers et l'idée
allemand et je cherche peut-être un
concurrent qui pourraient peut-être être
moins fort
mais je voudrais le prêt à l'heure où on
est actuellement 15 mois au bouquin
quatorze mois après l'annonce ce que le
bureau de la concurrence ne dit pas
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il arrive ce mets ton
admettons que la compliquer la question
ne se fait pas mais déjà la concurrence
est déjà amoindri comme ça aurait de la
difficulté à lancer la 5g avec ce qu'ils
ont maintenant par rapport à ce qu'ils
n'ont pas participé une enchère de
fréquences l'an dernier à coup sûr de la
question et à laquelle monsieur péladeau
quand même dépensé plus que 801 millions
de dollars pour acheter des fréquences
alex au québec mais aussi à l'extérieur
du québec toronto vancouver en alberta
donc lui s'est positionné et lui s'est
positionné en faisant cette acquisition
de spectre mais ce serait complémentaire
à l'acquisition de freedom oui ça
grosses sommes ça va ensemble parce que
voyez frieden avait participé l'an
chance s'ils n'avaient pas eu d'entente
avec match qu'ils auraient sûrement
participer à l'enchère et il avait des
frais il y avait des fréquences
réservées pour ce que les gens qu'on
appelle les nouveaux entrants ou les
régionaux et puis bon ils sont ils sont
pas pointés y ont pas participé pour
maximiser leurs chances de succès de la
fusion donc là
quebecor a participé dans l'enchère est
à acheter ces fréquences réservé là à
toronto alberta qu'on vous tenez
manitoba et en acheter pour beaucoup
parce que y ont acheté pour plus que 825
829 millions puisque la moitié ou 57% de
ceux qui étaient à l'extérieur de leur
territoire donc soumise c'est un gros
investissement déjà déjà donc 825
millions et quebecor père est conviée
pour acheter freedom mais là
ça c'est une bonne question les chiffres
qu'on a entendu c'est trois points
jusqu'à 7,5 milliards oui donc ce qui
pourrait faire baisser ce prix là compte
tenu que rogers et shaw sont un peu
acculé au pied du mur oui peut-être
peut-être il ya beaucoup de choses en
ligne ici donc peut-être que les gens
existants xplornet t accueilli pourrait
peut-être bonifié lors il ya aussi
quebecor qui peut-être pourrait faire
une offre intéressante évidemment s'il
dépose une offre trop faible alors
peut-être que bombardier ça ne vaut plus
la peine ils ont un frais de rupture
avec jade 1.2 mairie clients 1,2
milliard et peut-être que c'est ça qui
ferait finalement si on ne peut pas
savoir comment ça peut évoluer mais
c'est sûr que quebecor quand même je
pense un peu de levier négociations est
ce que quebecor est mieux placé que
jamais dans cette situation là pour
faire la question de freedom si on
regarde juste ces éléments alors oui je
pense qu'ils sont très bien placés et
ils sont par contre ils ont aussi des
challenge juste au québec le lancement
de la 5g tout ça c'est beaucoup de
challenge et il ya aussi des règles au
niveau du crtc qui ont changé aussi
l'année dernière comme avec les
fréquences qu'ils ont pu acheter
ailleurs il pourrait lancer
se lancer le mobile mais sur une base
virtuel partout ils ont acheté des
fréquences il pourrait lancer le mobile
par exemple il pourrait lancer le mobile
à toronto à vancouver sans avoir à
déployer le réseau ce mois pour une
période de temps alors que j'ai couru
dans le court ce que j'écoute pourrait
être un participant dans ce parce qu'ils
ont acheté des fréquences dans certaines
régions il on les avait déjà d'autres
fréquences ku qui n'ont pas déployé et
ils ont été achetés à toronto et toronto
star
quand même importance du genre dans la
donne donc cogeco pour effet pas faire
partie de l'équation mais pas pour
l'ensemble de freedom je crois ok
dossier qu'on suit de près jouanno mais
merci d'avoir été c'est moi qui vous
remercie pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]